staying home and staying inside means
many of us are discovering skills we
never knew we had many of them in the
kitchen for some reason baking bread has
become a big thing flour has been flying
off the shelves and is being kneaded
into dough by novice bakers across the
country our micro lay is one of them and
we asked him to explore what it is about
bread and baking it from scratch that's
become the perfect pandemic pastime
there's something in the way bread makes
us feel fresh out of the oven a pad of
butter melting in the first cut studies
have shown the aroma of fresh bread
makes us happy kinder which isn't a bad
thing considering where the world is at
right now even in defeat there's a
certain satisfaction at having tried
this no doubt she did some searches
online for baking she wouldn't be alone
Google Trends shows that by the first
week of April Canadians were asking how
to bake 10 times more than normal
that's when Emily oven ok her last name
is actually heaven began a popular
thread called how to make sourdough at
the end of the world which is clearly a
bit dramatic but less so when you hear
her talk about bread usually if you just
like show up for it every day keep
feeding it a few weeks so and so many of
us did with various degrees of success
for every golden crusty loaf there were
10 fails like this but slowly we started
to get better at it allowing a home
bakers like AB 10 as her pazu to share
the wealth but I think it's actually
helping me become a bit more popular
amongst my friends cuz now like I'll
just do a big batch and put it in like a
bag for a friend and then we'll just
drop it off over the past century
homemade bread went from being a staple
to a luxury let's face it who had the
time to bake before
in many ways this pandemic has created
the perfect conditions to try new things
isolation has taken away so much yet
it's given me two new family members
there's Magnus the pug and this a twenty
kilo bag of flour anybody who's done any
baking knows just how glorious it is and
if I need to explain baking ingredients
most notably flour sold out early and
have been very slow to get restocked
in fact we reached out to some
independent flour mills to talk about
demand only one agreed to speak on the
condition of anonymity seriously so we
animated the conversation I can't handle
any promotion right now he told us I'm
only filling 60% of my orders I can't
keep up so you're running out of flour I
asked no he said still stressed out I
have enough flour I'm running out of
bags and yet it's the run on yeast that
has led to the most confusing of
conversations
how old is your starter my starter what
do you mean the starter as Baker
extraordinaire and Food Network Canada
star Anna Olson pointed out to me is
necessary for anybody who can't procure
yeast to make dough rise its flour water
and the time to allow it to ferment and
create a natural yeast that said the
bread I made with store-bought yeast
garnered rave reviews so this is what I
made Oh nicely done
I'm impressed Mike my Dutch oven loaf so
painstakingly made over six hours of
kneading and rising and baking has now
been validated by none other than Anna
Olson and what she says about her craft
makes sense baking is a family affair
just as ingredients measured together
just so can make the perfect cake
getting the right mix of anything in a
bowl is the recipe for a happy household
young family she says they're asking her
about claw songs pancakes waffles and
cookies
you making French macaron making come on
dog covered cake like this it's it's
that next level up to court so there's a
three elite and even and if you've never
baked before starting with French
macaron well but be a bit of a challenge
one worth taking on provided the
ingredients are available but I suspect
more Canadians today will rise to the
challenge
[Music]